[Música]
de acordo com a organização mundial da
saúde o brasil é hoje o país com maior
percentual de ansioso do mundo 9,3 por
cento da população brasileira sofre com
algum tipo de transtorno de ansiedade
5,3 por cento da população brasileira
está depressiva nesse auditório que hoje
seria como se 36 pessoas já estivessem
com depressão
é como se 12 milhões de brasileiros ou
seja a população da cidade de são paulo
inteira estivesse depressiva e eu me
pergunto estamos conectados com o que
muda disse o seguinte a verdade não está
fora
a verdade está dentro de nós então eu
quero propor pra todos nós três conexões
ou três reconexões a verdade não está lá
fora a verdade está dentro de nós a
primeira conexão autoconhecimento quem é
você
quantas vezes a gente já respondeu essa
frase de verdade quem é você
nós esquecemos mas o nosso maior poder
vem de dentro não vem de fora
quem é você autoconhecimento também é
você se conectar algo maior que você a
sua crença sua religião a sua fé mas se
reconnect com você
segunda conexão se re connect com os
outros
hoje nós estamos muito distantes estamos
perto mas desconectados e conectar se
com o outro requer muita paciência e
muita inteligência emocional muito bem
muito respeito e muita entrega conectar
se com os outros e também se conectar
com a natureza universo ao nosso redor
quantas vezes a gente contempla a gente
pára para contemplar a natureza o
universo sem ter que tirar uma foto
apostar no instagram ou no facebook ou
em qualquer rede social se conectar com
a natureza com os cachorros com os
animais terceira conexão se reconectar
conectar com as idéias nós precisamos
urgentemente nos conectar a boas idéias
velhas idéias novas idéias mas boas
idéias quantas histórias existem no
mundo no brasil na américa latina
no brasil são mais de 207 milhões de
pessoas um só na américa latina mais 200
milhões 7 bilhões quase 8 bilhões no
mundo ea maioria das histórias como a
gente está vendo aqui hoje sedex são
melhores são boas histórias são bons
exemplos mas muitas vezes a gente
esquece de se conectar com as pessoas e
eu tenho certeza que todos nós todos
vocês que estão aqui hoje todos nós em
algum momento da nossa vida nós perdemos
essas conexões reconectam anos
rejeitamos ou voltamos a nos conectar
eu mesmo tive uma infância muito boa
muito boa mesmo não posso reclamar da
minha infância onde eu era conectado
como as idéias estudar em boas escolas
tive um bom conhecimento onde era
conectado com as pessoas era muito a meu
relacionamento com os meus pais com as
minhas irmãs meus amigos era sensacional
e eu era conectado com as idéias na
minha infância saber exatamente o que eu
queria ser na minha vida de infância
porém eu cresci chegou à adolescência e
eu posso falar que esse foi um momento
onde particularmente para mim eu perdi
as três conexões porque quando chegou à
adolescência eu cresci e me tornei muito
muito muito muito magro
como era muito muito muito muito magro
a minha cabeça cresceu mais do que o meu
corpo e naquela época a gente década de
90 o bullying era um esporte praticado o
tempo todo nas escolas a zoação né era
pesada ea zona euro com todo mundo mas
talvez por eu ter tido uma infância
muito boa eu não estava suportando
aquelas doações
eu não suportava talvez a constância a
frequência e ter sido o centro dos
ataques verbais os meus colegas e nesse
momento eu comecei a me conectar de mim
mesmo
a minha autoestima e autoconfiança
tudo foi me perdendo e nesse momento a
minha maior companheira da adolescência
chegou a gagueira é verdade
o gago ele não se torna gago ele nasce e
morre gago
então a gagueira não entrar não tem cura
tem tratamento e eu acho que a gagueira
ataca as pessoas no momento ela se sim
sentir mais vulnerável
e é exatamente como eu me sentia na
minha adolescência totalmente vulnerável
eu não tinha capacidade de conversar com
uma pessoa não tinha a coragem de chegar
em alguém para me relacionar por que a
maior dificuldade de um gago é se
conectar com as pessoas e se fazer
entender
e neste momento também me tornei
depressivo e talvez a gente tenha uma
tendência a minimizar o sofrimento das
crianças e dos nossos jovens e isso é
muito perigoso
somente quem está sofrendo aquilo sabe o
que sofreu
às vezes a gente quer comparar um
sofrimento das pessoas isso não existe
nesse momento de total o sofrimento eu
tinha vergonha de ser quem era eu tinha
vergonha do meu corpo eu tinha vergonha
da minha fala eu tinha vergonha de me
relacionar com as pessoas
eu tinha vergonha de ser quem era eu não
sei exatamente como isso mudou tem que
ser totalmente sincero com vocês mas
começou a mudar quando eu me conectei
com a minha dor e hoje eu me reconectar
continua sendo aquele jovem diferente
aquele menino gago mas que hoje cada vez
mais se conecta com as idéias para se
conectar com as pessoas para se conectar
comigo mesmo e com a minha missão que é
apoiar outras pessoas a se conectarem
com elas mesmo porque como já disse
jesus de nazaré
quem sabe tudo mas não conhece a si
próprio
são os mais carentes muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]